everyone's really excited about virtual
reality the oculus is just around the
corner I guess that one's waiting to get
them for Easter or perhaps next
Christmas and so I thought it would be
interesting to kind of broaden out the
discussion of virtual reality a bit and
put it in context
think about how it relates to augmented
reality and a few other ideas and so
more broadly that means introducing the
topic of mixed reality
about vrn AR and all these kind of
buzzwords so tell me what what's mixed
reality well yeah to tell you what mixed
reality is I really need to draw you a
picture I think that's the only way
we're gonna get through this and so this
is a picture that was proposed by couple
of researchers called Milgram and Casino
back in the early 1990s and they called
it the reality virtuality continuum
lovely name bit of a mouthful so I'll
just call it mixed reality if that's
okay mixed reality continuum and if
they're watching I hope they'll forgive
me
here is the universe of mixed reality
and to understand what this line means
it's a good idea to look at the end
points so first of all at this end we'll
call it physical reality or everyday
reality this is the everyday physical
world actually ideally if you went back
to pre 1950 no computers no digital okay
just as it was so if I put where we are
now in this office we're we're actually
kind of probably sitting here because
inescapably we've got some phones and
there's some digital stuff going on in
the background to vote at this end is
broadly physical stuff let's get to the
other end
here's virtual reality in the sense that
virtual reality is an illusion you're
trying to give someone the sense that
they have left the physical world behind
and being transported into a digital
world created by the computer and
they've become immersed in this world so
that's things like oculus rift and is it
at that end I've gotten cut out pictures
that I've carefully prepared over
breakfast this morning so let's kind of
position some technologies here is our
soon to be friendly oculus rift that
everyone's excited about so we thought
but on a head-mounted display and so the
physical world is blocked out and the
digital world is introduced and you hear
it as well the head mounts have been
around since all seventies eighties I'm
sure someone will correct me on that so
here's an earlier picture of a head
mount from 20 years ago and they're
wearing some data gloves that are
tracking their hand movements and kind
of various other things I think it was
1994 that computer Weekly was telling us
that VR would be a mainstream phenomenon
within three months so take your take
from that what you want and here's a
simulator this is a car cynicism other
way of doing VR and I know you've talked
about caves
computer file so there's all these kind
of gubbins that's about getting people
in a virtual world and I'm going to
position this here so that's not right
at the end of that no it's not is it
what would be right at the end of the
line I guess right at the end of the
line would be taking your brain out of
your body and putting it in a jar and
wiring it into the computer directly or
possibly even turning you completely
into an AI or some other sci-fi thing so
clearly you can go beyond things like
the oculus and you can have more tactile
interfaces that are prodding the whole
body or whatever and in science fiction
you can imagine how you completely
remove someone from the physical world
so yeah I wouldn't quite put the oculus
at right at the end of the picture I
don't think that's given us a sense if
you like of the two end points the two
extremes there's some interesting things
that live in between those so let's talk
about another thing that that people get
very excited about I draw a line about
half way then I'm gonna write augmented
reality on this side of the line so why
am I doing this because I think with
augmented reality you're trying to give
people the sense that they remain in the
everyday physical world but you're
introducing more and more digital stuff
into that world and you're kind of
overlaying it on the world as if it were
connected or part of it and how far
along the line you are depends on the
technology you use so now there's a few
others where all the way up somewhat
correct me yeah I'll put it sideways let
me not quite sure these microsoft
hololens project that was talked to
earlier this year which is a see-through
head mounted display that tracks where
you're looking and various other things
so it overlays the virtual world on your
everyday physical experience let's get
the Google glass in there there it is I
think I'd be tempted to position it a
bit further along the line here it's not
quite as immersive in the digital sense
you're kind of more in the physical
world we can debate this but you get the
point there's different levels of where
you're on the line there's other things
of course here's a mobile phone or a
tablet that I'm holding up augmented
reality style or somebody is and it's
overlaying labels about the world so
here you're kind of getting closer to
physical reality but you're kind of you
can position yourself along the line but
all of these leave you in the physical
world Westwego next let's move a bit
closer to physical reality and just
complete the picture there so here you
start to get a bunch of other stuff you
get ubiquitous computing I might think
that what ubiquitous computing is about
is more and
or embedding the digital experience into
the everyday physical and you end up
with her the latest incarnation people
are talking about the Internet of Things
for example he kind of lives in this
space you know now your experience is
really with everyday physical stuff like
mugs but those mugs contain sensors and
the digital is kind of hidden within
them so you you're pushing the
experience at this end now I'm probably
asking for a fight here because the
original definition of ubiquitous
computing by Mark Weiser from Xerox PARC
he wrote a fair bit about how it was
sort of the antithesis of virtual
reality and possibly mixed reality maybe
that's okay I suppose I positioned it
here quite a long way from it so so so
maybe it is well there's a gap there's a
gap kind of here and it's interesting
thing what lives in this space then what
is it where you believe you're in a
virtual world but it's really quite
connected to the physical and this is a
kind of this is a Milgram Casinos
concept of augmented virtuality I think
the easiest way to think of it is it's
virtual worlds that are made live that
you're in a virtual world but the
digital stuff you're experiencing is
driven by real events in the real world
that are being sensed possibly in real
time or something that's close enough to
real time that it has a feeling of being
live so what could that look like well
here's a few examples this is a one from
quite a long way back one simple way of
doing this is to punch video windows
into the virtual world virtual worlds
are made up of polygons or the textures
on them and you can make those textures
be a live video and then you can
essentially have a window in the world
where you walk up to it and you look out
and you're you're looking into reality
somewhere with this office or in this
case it's a guy who's made his face live
so his avatar his character's walking
around the virtual world but with a
video face yeah so you kind of punched a
hole in virtual reality and you're
looking out another way of doing it is
essentially what Google are doing with
Google Earth so his the Google car in
that they are building a virtual world
Google Earth that he's made by scanning
the real world although they're
currently not strictly live you know
that they're live ish I don't know what
the refresh rate is is a couple of years
maybe I don't know how often that car
comes down your street but but they are
refreshing the world so it's on a very
slow update it's just not on frames per
second it's yeah
Millenia yeah frames per decade but as
we get more and more drones or people
mobile camera or whatever is going on
out there then of course that refresh
rate is going to speed up and we'll end
up with a Google Earth maybe that's much
more live and you can see some of this
some lovely videos out on the internet
that show things like plane data coming
as you see these over Europe and you can
see you know it's still not real time
but you get a sense that if you could
track planes as they were flying you
would actually see the journeys that are
being made right now or whatever
I think augmented virtuality perhaps
doesn't feel quite with us yet but you
can see some early glimpses of where we
might end up in this spectrum so there's
another kind of bit we can we can fill
in we've drawn the picture this is that
if you like the universe of mixed
reality a lot of the technologies and
certainly the underlying software
techniques are actually quite similar
here a lot of these involve being able
to track people's movements and head
positions and objects in a world a lot
of them use graphics in different ways
even the devices are quite common on we
see headsets on both sides of the line
but it's whether you can kind of see
through them or not you know I think
that things like augmented reality and
virtual reality are not really different
things what they are is different
experiences of the same thing which is
mixed reality it's tempting to think
that you're in you know just one of
these you're either doing augmented
reality I've got my phone now or I'm
doing virtual reality I've got my oculus
on but actually there are experiences
that mix them up and move between them
in really interesting ways so for
example like in the naughties group of
artists called blast fearing Maeda
a really lovely game in which you could
play it in in two ways there were a
bunch of people who are on the streets
of a city running around they had
handheld devices that showed them a kind
of a live map of where other people were
in this game and they were tracked with
GPS and then there was a bunch of
players who were online in a virtual
model of the same cities they were
logged in over the Internet and they
could see where the people on the
streets were and the people on the
streets could see where they were and
then the two of them had a game of Chase
basically the people in the streets
chase these people and as they went
audio streams
were captured from the people on the
city and they kind of went out to the
online players and the fun here if
you're an online player was again it was
not a nice example of augmented
virtuality you could tune into the
sounds of this person running through
the city so you could hear the traffic
and you could hear them being out of
breath and then you could figure out
things like okay the right game tactic
is to work out where the hills are and
if my avatar runs up the hill which
doesn't hurt me at all this poor sucker
is going to be laboring and I'll hear it
and then so on so that's a lovely
example of an experience that
deliberately mixes up these and also you
could head out of gain territory and
think about other situations so let's
think about them so my colleagues have
worked on emergency and disaster
management where you've got a big
command and control problem so with
disaster management you've got people on
the ground
yeah out there in the field who are
trying to rescue people or you know
solve problems wearing whatever got
handheld devices or possibly even kind
of heads-up displays but also you've got
people back at base in a control room
who are trying to coordinate get an
overview of the effort so you know any
that kind of command and control
situation is a classic example of where
you probably want to mix augmented
virtuality and augmented reality in some
kind of more flexible way stealth and
botnets usually go hand-in-hand because
from the point of view of a CNC server
it wants to ensure and some years ago it
seems the NSA got a backdoor in one of
these routers presumably because they
got one of their people to get a job